if you're boarding a big aircraft the
kind of large Boeing or Airbus that goes
across the Atlantic you'll probably get
on and off the plane using a Jet Bridge
that's the movable extendable Corridor
that connects the terminal to the plane
but sometimes the plane will have to
park at what's called a remote stand
just a spot that's assigned in the
middle of the tarmac and so as the rain
piles down some cold and tired airport
staff will roll a set of stairs up and
you end up riding a slow and crowded
Airport bus instead I guess you do get
to skip the long walk through the
terminal and it's great if you the sort
of Aviation geek who likes looking
behind the scenes at an airport but it's
not ideal if you have a connection to
make it could have been very different
the last time I flew into Montreal here
in Canada the aircraft door opened and
on the other side was what looked like a
strange bus on stilts there were three
of them passenger transport Vehicles
ptvs one connected to each door of the
plane and I figured I had a new video
idea we have eight ptvs that are in use
right now at Montreal chudo Airport of
course we always strive to do gating
directly but during summer season or
some peak season during winter time we
have no choice but to use remote parking
during our peak season on a regular day
we receive a bit more than 500 flights
here at Montreal Trudeau and of those
500 flights about 10 to 15 of them will
be remotely gated with a PTV the idea
came from legendary architect AOS
saronin as part of his plan for
Washington Del airport which still also
uses them the original name was mobile
Lounge they were promoted in a short
film produced by his friends equally
legendary designers Charles and Ray Ames
and that film shows exactly the sort of
late 50s luxury techno optimism that
wouldn't survive the next few decades
sarin's original plan was that airport
terminals would work much like they do
now but smaller with boarding doors
close together when it was time to board
a mobile Lounge would dock to the
terminal everyone would get on board and
they'd be taken out to the remote stand
in Comfort less space needed less
walking less noise near the terminal
easier for
everyone and it worked there are photos
of mobile lounges lined up outside brand
new shiny terminals that were designed
for them when passengers see them
arriving they know that they're not
going to have to go outside in the rain
in the snow with their luggage for
people with reduced Mobility it's more
efficient for parents and all the stuff
that goes with traveling with children
it's easier a PTV can welcome between
100 and 120 passenger per trip while a
regular bus is more in the mid 775
passengers Montreal's ptvs here are a
more modern variant called the plane
mate the original lounges were smaller
than this and instead of lifting up on
stilts they extended a boarding ramp
that went out at an incline because the
planes they were connecting to were
smaller too back then a fully loaded jet
might have 100 passengers the largest
modern planes have four or five times
that and airport terminals were getting
bigger not just to accommodate planes
but also sheer numbers of people now
these newer versions are bigger and to
dock with the plane they lift themselves
up with a screwdrive those big lumps on
the top they to cover up the poles that
the entire cabin is lifting itself along
we do the maintenance and operations of
the ptvs we acquired the manufacturing
rights in the year 2000 so we have all
the engineering drawings and everything
I would say now we got a down to
probably less than 20% that is custom
the rest is off the shelf parts that we
can get we have built new ones and right
now we are looking at retrofitting them
to electrical our mechanics every day do
a walk around we guarantee
99.8% efficiency to the airport so why
didn't these end up being used around
the world Aeros saronin blamed the cost
and that was certainly a factor planes
getting bigger was another and the
former head of the Washington airports
Authority said that passengers don't
like them because we want autonomy we
want to get off the damn plane and walk
for a bit under our own power but if you
ask me I think the main reason is that
in 1958 the same year that animated film
was made the first modern jetbridge was
also installed there was one victory for
that luxury techno optimism though the
end of that film Shows mobile lounges at
a surely soon to arrive Spaceport and
while sadly no one's boarding PanAm
flight to the Moon anytime soon NASA did
buy a couple of plane mates for
astronaut transport there's nothing
wrong with mobile lounges they still
work well here in Montreal but when
airports were expanding and had to
choose most of them decided that jet
Bridges were just a little bit easier
and
cheaper I'm not allowed to drive this by
the way like thank you to everyone from
Montreal Airport for for letting me sit
here and for all the access they've
given me but um I'm not allowed to drive
this